brasil bajo presión el coronavirus ya
dejó más de 180 mil muertos en el país
el segundo más golpeado del mundo
acabamos de entrar a una paciente de 30
años con diabetes gestacional dio a luz
en una unidad de cuidados intensivos
hace unos días
queremos que la gente se entere de que
esta enfermedad no hace diferencia según
la edad ni la raza
después de un periodo de respiro el
coronavirus ha vuelto a presionar las
redes de hospitales de las grandes
ciudades de brasil al menos siete de las
27 capitales del país ya sobrepasaron el
90% de ocupación de camas de cuidados
intensivos
si tenemos solo una cama de cuidados
intensivos quién va para esa cama si hay
tres o cuatro ambulancias con pacientes
graves quién va para la cama quién elige
es el médico
romer a casi diez meses de la
confirmación del primer caso de kobe 19
en el país los profesionales de la salud
llegan a navidad agotados por la presión
emocional y física de su trabajo con sap
y shout cansados exhaustos sentimos que
estamos envejeciendo más de lo normal
tenemos compañeros con depresión
tenemos varios colegas afectados por
depresión
las últimas cifras contraponen al
presidente de ultraderecha
revolucionario quien decidió ignorar
esta segunda ola el jueves afirmando que
brasil estaba al final de la pandemia
sin embargo los expertos alertan sobre
la posibilidad de un escenario aún más
sombrío tras las reuniones familiares de
fin de año y ante este panorama varios
estados se recrudecieron las medidas de
distanciamiento social con toques de
queda prohibición de la venta de alcohol
y limitaciones en el número de personas
que puedan acudir a playas y zonas de
recreación